Vsauce!
Kevin here, I’m gonna play a song I wrote
just for you.
Ready?
Here we go.
[drill noise] Wait, is this a song?
Is a drill… music?
Actually let’s back up a second.
Like all the way back.
Let’s put you back in the womb.
Hey, can you hear me?
You’re listening to your first song.
That consistent rhythm is the beat of your
mother’s heart.
The uterine blood and amniotic fluid flowing
around you create that gentle drone.
Consonants and high frequency sounds are filtered
by the layers of skin and fat in your mother’s
abdomen, but you can hear a soft melody of
low frequency bass and vowels.
Your eyelids are closed until 28 weeks after
conception, but you start to hear at week
18.
Before even knowing there’s a world to see,
you’re immersed in a world of music.
Ah, you’ve been born!
Welcome to humanity -- and your brain has
gifted you with musicality.
While music is a social and cultural construct,
meaning that it’s something we create ourselves,
musicality describes the mental processes
that underlie musical behavior and perception.
Your brain is trained to respond to emotional
and intonational aspects of the human voice,
an important feature of human biology.
Despite only an 8% body mass difference, adult
males have a voice about 50% deeper than females.
Your brain adapts to processing information
being delivered at different pitches, but
studies show Tweety Bird and the rest of the
animal kingdom have trouble with this.
Relative pitch allows you recognize relationships
between notes to transpose the same tune in
a different key.
So if you hear “Mary Had A Little Lamb”
sung in a high pitch by Mickey Mouse or in
a low pitch by Darth Vader, you’ll still
recognize that it’s “Mary Had A Little
Lamb.”
Tweety Bird and Curious George would think
they were completely different songs.
Okay, humans notice the nuance of pitch.
But what happens when you lose the sense of
hearing or never had it in the first place?
The brains of the deaf and hard of hearing
can rewire to feel music rather than hear
it.
The information is processed in the brain
similarly to how others hear sound.
Even without the ability to hear, music finds
its way into our bodies.
And for some people that experience results
in feeling...meh!
An estimated 4% of humans lack musicality.
Amusia is an inability to recognize pitch
changes and can include problems with musical
recognition and memory.
This causes difficulty understanding not only
the emotion of music, but also nuances of
language.
Like being able to distinguish the pitch change
that differentiates statements from questions.
This is a statement.
This is a question?
And their short-term pitch sequence memory
deficiency prevents amusics from forming the
story of music in their minds -- to remember
the pitches they’ve heard, to anticipate
their repetition, and to be aroused by their
changes.
Yet some can process pitch and still not derive
any gratification from music.
Most people physiologically react to pleasurable
music with higher skin conductance and heart
rate, but researchers found that people with
musical anhedonia show no relationship between
musical enjoyment and a physiological response.
While music can give most people chills, a
dopamine increase in the nucleus accumbens,
music to them is just kinda...friend-zoned.
These musical disorders show us that music
isn’t just about processing sound -- it’s
about using that sound to understand the thoughts
and feelings of others.
An education that begins after the doctor
slaps your tiny butt cheeks and your mom starts
babbling in your crying cute little infant
face.
Baby talk or Motherese is a type of speech
marked by exaggerated pitch.
Our earliest understanding of verbal communication
involves Prosody, the rhythmic patterns of
stress and intonation in language.
“Mama.
Dada.”
Without that pitch change it sounds emotionless,
robotic and kinda creepy.
“MAMA.”
Studies show babies pay more attention when
they hear exaggerated pitch, length, and timbre.
Their brains love the excitement of surprises.
Pitch can matter a lot to meaning; it’s
so important in Mandarin Chinese that the
same word can have completely different meanings
based on how you say it.
“Ma” can mean mother, lazy, hemp or horse.
Before kids learn syntax, they may learn the
building blocks of language through The Alphabet
Song.
Which comes from a French folk song Mozart
popularized in ‘Twelve Variations on ’Ah
vous dirai-je, Maman’ -- later becoming
Baa, Baa Black Sheep and Twinkle, Twinkle
Little Star.
It’s a popular tune.
Not only does musicality help with language
and predates the alphabet song, musicality
predates the alphabet itself... and all written
language.
By a lot.
Middle Age bards, Beethoven, and Beyoncé
didn't invent musical communication.
Before our ancestors developed writing -- values,
memories, and customs were conveyed through
song.
Sacred song-cycles honored the Gods, passed
down histories and were the essential medium
of memory.
Ethnomusicologist John Blacking suggests singing
and dancing preceded homo sapiens by several
hundred thousand years.
Caves are full of acoustic reverberations,
like your shower, that must’ve made Caveman
Ugg feel like Pavarotti.
But Ugg couldn’t just make noise - Ugg needed
notes.
Unlike noise which features sharp, erratic
waveforms, notes are repeating ripple patterns
of sound.
A hammer hitting a nail creates an irregular
ripple of air pressure while a flute can create
a consistent ripple that repeats over and
over.
An easy way to produce notes is with a column.
Flutes and clarinets vibrate the air within
a column.
Strings are columns that can vibrate.
Pressing a tightly-stretched string against
the neck of an instrument shortens its length,
which alters its vibration and pitch.
The consistent whirring of a spinning drill
produces a musical note and sustaining it
is a form of drone music.
Controlling notes and creating music make
audible order out of nature’s chaos.
Darkness is scary and overwhelming because
you can’t see what danger may be lurking...
but you can renew your comfort with light.
Silence reflects the absence of life.
We often say it’s, “Dead quiet.”
But you can fight back with sound.
And in that battle, you form a relationship
with people you’ll never meet.
As the language of emotion and physiological
arousal, music is a fundamental method of
connecting you to others.
Preliterate tribes used music to unify the
group in times of danger; songs are used in
religious services to coalesce the group.
In music, collaborating becomes proof that
the sum can be greater than its individual
parts.
Music welds you together with others at parties,
clubs, weddings, work, and even funerals.
Concerts are a celebration of collective cultural
unity.
In movies, music reinforces and heightens
the emotion of the scene.
National anthems reflect the history, values,
and dreams of entire countries made up of
millions of people past, present, and future.
Music unites what you see, what you hear,
what you think, and what you feel -- literally.
Sound physically touches you.
My voice is touching your ear drums and causing
them to go in and out.
I’m moving part of you with every word.
Music is so intrinsically tied to our motor
systems that children have difficulty remaining
still when singing.
A study of music’s effects on exercise showed
cyclists who synchronized their movement with
music required 7% less oxygen than those who
didn’t.
The rhythm and tempo of music can unlock
the body for sufferers of Parkinson’s disease,
freeing them to move despite the disease freezing
their movement.
It’s the soundtrack to our motion and behavior
- consciously and subconsciously.
Background music in stores influences shoppers
to stay longer and buy more.
If classical music is playing in a liquor
store, you’re more likely to buy more expensive
wine.
If French music is playing, you’re more
likely to buy French wine.
Music drives cultural behaviors -- and connects
us to time, which is why songs arouse a strong
sense of nostalgia.
Your head is like a jukebox with eyeballs.
The songs you know become part of your mental
catalog, and you’re able to recall them
with incredible accuracy.
Earworms are those catchy, bits of music that
repeat over and over sometimes called “involuntary
musical imagery.”
It’s also possible to remember almost
nothing but music.
In his book, Musicophilia, Oliver Sacks tells
the tale of former renowned musician and conductor
Clive Wearing who, after a brain infection,
had virtually his entire memory erased.
Retrograde amnesia left him unable to recall
his past and his anterograde amnesia only
allows his short term memory to last only
up to 30 seconds.
After every handful of blinks, Clive’s eyes
open to a brand new world.
His subsequent loneliness, confusion and constant
fear left him feeling robbed of consciousness.
He says, “It’s like being dead.”
In an attempt to regain control of his life,
he started keeping a journal.
But the entries amounted to simply repeating
the same sentiment and crossing out the previous
one.
This time properly awake.
This time finally awake.
This time completely awake.
One of Clive’s only portals back his life
is his wife, Deborah.
To him, her visits to the facility where he
lives are a miracle, resulting in sobbing
and clinging to her presence.
But within minutes of her departure he leaves
messages for her saying, “Please come and
see me, darling -- it’s been ages since
I’ve seen you.
Please fly here at the speed of light.”
She would’ve had to travel at the speed
of light to get there before Clive forgot
that he needed to see her.
The only other gateway to himself, the only
thing that holds him in the state of being
Clive -- is music.
He plays the piano, sings, and learns new
songs.
While eating a chocolate bar, he is constantly
surprised by how the bar is changing because
he forgets that he has been eating it.
But as he plays music, his symptoms are suspended
temporarily.
Music allows a precious moment in which Clive
Wearing is…
Clive Wearing again.
The momentum of the music briefly keeps him
afloat before sinking back down into that
lost place.
Through music, he stays awake...completely
awake...until the song is over.
An 1886 painting by George Frederic Watts
depicts Hope as a blindfolded woman sitting
on the globe, clutching a broken harp and
desperately listening to the sound of a single,
frail string -- the only one that remains.
As long as you have music and the ability
to embrace meaning from the sounds around
you, you cannot be alone.
That is…
Hope.
And as always - thanks for watching.